hey guys how are you so I am super
excited because I got a chance to sit
down with Vince Vaughn and the rest of
the cast of internship and do an
interview sort of I brought one of my
favorite childhood games operation to
play obviously they'd like any normal
person would I just sat down to edit all
of you footage from the interviews and
realize there was about 40 minutes and I
decide to break that into three separate
videos so I made a playlist okay list
will be right here so you can either
click on that or click on the link in
the description to watch all three back
to back if you're not a fan a playlist
that's okay don't worry I'll just put
the links all in the descriptions and
you can just click to your heart's
desires that's why we were hanging out
with mr. O'Brien to mr. Wilson and a
bunch of other people and it was nice to
see you in person as they should put
your hand in so you can see the nails no
that's not it yes a thing it is